see the squid i did see this no one is
allowed to talk about the [ __ ] squid
until i don't see this way you haven't
seen it she hasn't seen even a full
episode i've been living she's been
sleeping i haven't i've been under water
for a week
i didn't want to watch the squid in one
day
but i had to watch the squiddy one you
know what really really irks me is
before i left
about two weeks ago the first day that
squid game came out i told bobby please
can we watch this thing together so we
tuck ourselves put our little sleepy
hats on we're right side by side and
then 10 but maybe 15 minutes in he's
like i hate this thing and then he
started watching that documentary about
um l.a riots instead i love that level
that's good it's my favorite riot though
first of all l.a rides is my favorite
what's your top three right right and
then it goes l.a riots watts
okay all right also in l.a yeah that's
uh yeah that was a while i'm a big la
guy right and then there was one in
detroit
yeah and so many one in detroit yeah so
what happened is like the second day
good thank you man i leave town and the
second day he's like i finished the
whole show i finished a whole show yeah
yeah it's great yeah what
okay so unfair
can i just say something i want to
apologize to you
okay
number one
i'm the type of guy
that
no i cheat too you know
i'm a failure i'm a cheat i get it okay
i'm no good all right but i'm the type
of guy that i hadn't heard of the squid
games
when you said because you were watching
it so i started watching it right and in
the beginning
i didn't want it was good i just didn't
know anything about it and i don't like
i didn't like the fact that he stole
money from his mom
right so when you don't know no one i've
never heard of it before and i see this
piece of [ __ ] stealing an atm you know a
card from his mom's thing when she's
like definitely poor and then he's
gambling with it at that point i was
like i'm out of this you know i mean
because i don't like his um
vibe
yeah his
principles
right but then what happened was all
right
on tweets
people started tweeting me this is me
the [ __ ] off right here i just stop stop
for a second
my suggestion is not enough but listen
okay
let me finish all right get the tweets
right
and then the back
the black black
eric yes oh the black bag
what'd i say yeah black bag yeah black
bag black that's a good name for him
first of all thank you so much what's he
filled with yeah oatmeal okay
yeah black bag
so
the black bag told me you know you
should watch it
and then um we're gonna get so much
trouble for this he's gonna call hey now
you know bobby hey bobby you know
so um
and then a bunch of comics did
and then i read some things that was
like you know so it was like 10 things
and then you're like
now you're curious
you know i mean you become curious
because it becomes cultural cheddar
chatter so you get the chitter chatter
right so you watch the first one
and it's it's okay until
the last bit of it
right and then once you see the last bit
you go
i get what it is this is insane this is
cool right it's violent
and um the acting is really good
um i love koreans
and um
obviously i love koreans and it's a
really good show but um it's not for
everybody uh did you see it yeah all of
it just finished it this morning well
don't because i'm not done yet you
haven't even started you haven't even
started even done yet you haven't even
started will she like it you knowing her
well how far did you get in i'm still in
the first episode yeah so you you i just
got home please give me you're not at
the game yet so you
yeah anyway what do what's your review
i thought was pretty damn good
yeah yes my sister said she was like
[ __ ] hunger games is like trash
garbage compared to this it reminds me
of um
it's like battle royale right a little
bit of battle but it's got a little bit
of the host vibe
you know i mean the korean movie host
because there's humor in it right i
think he's very funny a great actor that
guy i don't know who he is he's kind of
like the korean ed norton
oh yeah
what pretty good same face same vibe
right so the korean ed norton
um
but there was some i was confused about
a little detail in the show
i thought those two were brothers but
they're not right
no okay
they're friends yeah they grew up
together
i don't know why i thought they were
brothers and maybe you just wanted them
i wanted them to be brothers yeah they
don't look anything like that oh are you
kind of playing it out like you and
steve scenario yeah jesus man
i wonder if my brother and i
because obviously there needs to be one
we're not giving anything away there's
one man standing right
and if it was my brother at the end you
know what i mean
i i would i know my answer so quickly
i would i would take it i would die i
wouldn't want my sister for quit but she
wouldn't want you to die wouldn't you
quit though i don't know what the game
is i'm not there yet but i certainly
know that i would take a bullet or any
type of arrow through my a dagger
through my chest or my sister
let me have to see if i would
play the scenario now i would want to
i don't think i would though
i mean i would want to you guys would
fight it out to the death i think we'd
be like quit first man i'm your older
brother of an argument right i see it
and he's like no bob i need to you know
you get me more money than me
right
you have to think about the logistics of
that because you have a mother to take
care of and mortgage to pay and all of
these things
i think that
you know if we're talking about you know
not no feelings at all i think that you
are the you have to be the one to stay
alive to take care of
that's right family i have to fight him
not make him quit but there is no
quitting right we're [ __ ] there's
quitting but there is no the you have to
do one thing and it's like the group has
to do it yeah so anyway watch the show
it's really good i also i've been
watching another thing called fearless
it's on on netflix oh yeah you did tell
me about that and it's about bull riding
yeah is it the gauchos
marks no gauchos like cowboys i don't
know what i got is that what they call
them what are they georgia yeah
these are brazilian ones oh yeah yeah
um the brazilians are the best one of
the best at rodeos at bulls bull riding
did you guys know that